wherever you are wherever you go someone  wants to murder you it's all kicking off  on Game of Thrones and season six starts  this sunday april twenty fourth and our  bodies are totally ready  so come join me Lucy James and my  Brotherhood without banners well my  colleagues here at Gamescom every monday  will be dissecting the latest episodes  fan theories and of course George RR  Martin's livejournal for answers to the  important questions like will Clegane  ball finally happen is Jon Snow really  dead what do the others actually want  does the dragon have three heads and of  course who is going to emerge victorious  and take the Iron Throne so make sure  you join us here every monday at  youtube.com slash gamespot for gamespot  of Thrones all men must subscribe Halle  juice for what you're about to see